the academy presents a scientific and
Engineering award to Howard Preston for
the concept design and engineering and
to Bernie Butler Smith for the design
and implementation of electronic
circuitry and software of the Preston
Cinema systems Light Ranger tube come on
up you guys
[Applause]
[Music]
thank you simu thank you members of the
Academy I am truly honored to accept
this award together with my wonderful
colleague Bernie the Light Ranger 2
project began nearly 10 years ago and
continues to evolve to this day to my
wonderful crew who were here this
evening sitting with us you've given
your heart and soul to this project for
these many years
thank you so much for your dedication
two Focus pullers broke new ground by
bringing bringing the first light Ranger
2 on set
this took conviction
courage and more than a little rehearsed
behind the scenes so I want to thank
Bob Smathers and janming for not only
leading the way but for generously
sharing your their experience advice
with newcomers helping them to master
this new technology
their advice and suggestions as well as
those coming from the nail large and
growing community of users have made the
light Ranger so successful
I'm tremendously grateful to all of you
in the focus polar community
and finally
the biggest thank you goes to my wife
artist Astrid her unquestioned support
for invention
creativity has made all I do possible
thank you
[Applause]
yeah I think the academy for this honor
I'm really honored by this award
and I thank my wife for being by my side
all these years I love you honey
and thank you Howard for your kind words
it's uh it's been a pleasure working
with Howard for these many years
developing technology
for the artists we both have a passion
to
create tools to make it easier for the
artists to do their work
and
it's been a pleasure working with
somebody like Howard who's very
Innovative and and
he's he's driven by the latest
technology and and
I work very closely with him in
designing
um this technology and that's it's been
a pleasure this this last decade working
with you thank you so much
and um
thank you for the team at at working at
Preston Cinema systems
um wonderful group of people working
with you guys
and
it's it's
um it's it's great working amongst such
creative people that
um
have a passion
for their work and and to to create the
art
um it's been a pleasure for me to work
in this field and I humbly accept this
award
um
and I thank you and and thank you
everyone
um that's it
[Applause]